[Music]
[Applause]
oh boy
i'm going old school on his butt
come on
granny's out here having a martini at
halftime
space jam july 16th
basketball camp is next weekend you got
amazing potential on the court
and i can help you get there that's not
what i want dad
you never let me do what i want to do
you never let me just
do me hold up wrong floor
fat will smith i gotta deal with this
what in the matrix hello
king james i am the king of this domain
this is the server-verse what'd you do
to my son where's dom
the only way you're getting your son
back is if you and i play a little
basketball
pete send this clown to the rejects
[Applause]
what is this
a cartoon what's up doc
i need to assemble an elite team to help
get my son back i know what you're
looking for
a dream team ma'am shoot the ball
let's try that again shall we
king james
[Music]
and get our son back
yikes
classic welcome to the space camp
i'm going old school on his butt
whoa welcome to the space jam
[Music]
so